ANDY QIN: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to APP 101 breakout.
Today we'd like to
introduce Google Distributed
Cloud, Hosting Mode.
My name is Andy Qin,
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud.
I'm here with my colleague Ray.
RAY COLLINE: Hi there.
I'm Ray Colline.
And I'm a software engineer,
who works on Google Cloud.
And it's great to be here.
ANDY QIN: In this
session, we'll first
look at market pain points,
and the limitations of existing
solutions.
And then we will
introduce Google solution
in terms of how it's
defined, and what's
the key streams and
the characteristics.
And we will then dive
deep into the product
areas, like platform,
services, and support.
Today the public clouds provide
amazing results and benefits.
So it seems everything is
moving to public Cloud.
But the reality is
that not all workloads
can move to public Cloud
for different reasons,
regulatory, IP protection,
sovereignty concerns.
Those workloads that
stayed private, it's
very challenging
for them to leverage
all the cool innovation
from Cloud technologies
to empower their business,
and, oftentimes, those
are very special and specific
part of their business.
As we in public clouds
the infrastructure
is quite transparent.
Users do not need to care about
the gory details of things
like hardware operation.
However, that's not the
case for private Cloud.
In the legacy private
Cloud customers
still have to
spend a lot of time
managing their infrastructure.
And most hobbyists pinpointed
that customers will end up
with a public Cloud
and private Cloud
with different development
models and toolings,
and the resulted inconsistency
impacts business agility.
The market pain
points are very clear,
but if you look at the
existing solutions out
in the marketplace they didn't
address all those pain points.
As we know, some products are
viewed on proprietary stack.
There's no consistency between
that and the public Cloud.
Applications developed in
private mode cannot be easily
ported to the public Cloud.
It's very difficult
to achieve write once,
and run anywhere [INAUDIBLE].
Some private Cloud products
a very infrastructure service
oriented.
No advanced Cloud innovations
like AI/ML services and data
analytics.
And the management
methodologies are very legacy.
For example, the more
declarative policy paradigm
is quite common in public
Cloud, but most private
Cloud are still using
the legacy imperative
tools to match their systems.
Some private Cloud products
do meet most requirements.
However, they require
connections back
to their Cloud region for the
quintupling to even function.
This poses a huge challenge
for sensitive workloads,
especially in the
specific market segments,
like defense and
critical infrastructure.
Google Cloud recognizes
those market pain points
and the clear gaps
in the marketplace.
We are going to offer a
solution that can directly
solve those challenges.
The solution is called Google
Distributed Cloud Hosted Mode.
There's three key things to
highlight on this solution.
First, it doesn't
require connections back
to public Cloud.
All quintupling, data plane,
match plane can be local.
It helps you meet
the sovereignty
and the regulatory requirements.
Second, it comes with
highly differentiated
advanced services, like
AI/ML and the data analytics.
We believe those services
are critical to empower
the customer to stay
competitive in their own market.
And the third, it leverages
open source and open API.
This provides an automated
portability and software
survivability, which are super
important to both business
agility and the
sovereignty needs.
At this particular
point in time,
the Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode
is still a pre-GA product.
We are working hard to bring
this to the market soon.
Besides the three
key things, I think
it's important to look
at the characteristics
and the key strengths of Google
Distributed Cloud Hosted Mode.
The name Hosted Mode tells a
lot about location and control.
The solution can be deployed
at a customer designated data
center, even in the totally
air gapped environment.
This solution is not just
the infrastructure play,
it comes with Google advanced
services, like AI/ML.
The power of those technologies
and Google's years of expertise
are no longer limited
to the public Cloud,
with Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode,
customers can now enjoy
those on their own premise.
Another strength
worth highlighting
is that the entire
solution is flexible.
It comes as pre-assembled
and preconfigured racks
and is delivered to your
data center as a service.
It can scale from 1
rack, to a couple racks,
and to hundreds of racks.
It has local
quintupling built in,
so it covers all sovereignty
dimensions, data sovereignty,
operational sovereignty,
and software sovereignty.
While it's built
by Google Cloud,
so it inherits the Cloud DNA.
Open and the Modern are
the design philosophies
we follow when we
build the solution.
We believe the solution
will meet the needs of many
industries, where they have
a sensitive workload and they
cannot move to the public Cloud,
but they still want to leverage
the modern innovation
from Cloud.
Public sector is a prime
example of those industries.
With that, let me
invite my colleague
Ray to talk about what
exactly is in the solution
and what are the
key capabilities.
RAY COLLINE: Thank you, Andy.
We're going to get into a little
bit of the technology that
makes up Google distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode.
And we'll start with the
lowest level, the hardware.
So at Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode
is full racks of hardware
optimized to deliver
an air gapped Cloud experience.
These racks include
modern hardware
from top OEM providers,
including HPE, NetApp,
and Cisco.
All of the
infrastructure management
is taken care of by
Google Distributed Cloud.
These are things like
operating system upgrades,
firmware upgrades, switch OS
upgrades, NetApp upgrades,
et cetera.
All are taken care of as part
of Google Distributed Cloud.
It also includes GPUs
for AI/ML workloads.
And it includes storage block--
or sorry, block, file,
and object storage
in a redundant manner.
It also includes high
performance networking.
And in fact, each node
has full bandwidth
to all the other nodes
within a GDC instance,
and these instances can
be up to 10,000 VCPUs.
In addition, it's
Kubernetes all the way down.
So Andy spoke earlier
about it being open, right?
We've taken that and we've
introduced Kubernetes APIs
all the way down into the
infrastructure management layer
so that the notion
of an OS upgrade
is actually controlled through
the reliability of Kubernetes.
Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode
is a full air gapped
Cloud solution stand alone
from any other Cloud,
and so it comes
with sophisticated
multi-tendency.
As we know in public
clouds things like GCP
have the notion of
organizations and projects,
and one creates a project
before doing anything on GPC,
creating a VM, creating a
cluster, creating a database.
Within Amazon, one creates an
account to do the same thing.
Well, GDC introduces the notion
of fleets and fleet namespaces
to provide that level of
resource management and tenancy
within a GPC instance.
Fleets are hardware
separated from each other,
allowing a single GPC instance
to serve multiple applications
with good security
guarantees between them.
And fleet namespaces,
like Amazon accounts
and GCP projects,
provide isolation
between teams and
components of applications.
Policy control is built
in from the beginning.
As we said earlier, we're
Kubernetes all the way down.
So all the APIs benefit from
having Anthos policy controller
based on OPA gatekeeper,
and Kubernetes emission
control, such that one
can govern all aspects
of the usage, and also audit.
This means you could,
for example, take a VM
and say no VMs can ever
have the name Ray in it,
and we could enforce such a
policy at that granularity.
It's also extensible
and customizable.
So Kubernetes APIs allow
for custom controllers
to do any sorts of things.
We've had customers
build controllers
that disallow
launching of new code
unless there's an
associated launch
process that's been approved.
And Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode
is a rich and open ecosystem.
Because it's built on
standard Kubernetes,
one could use the entire
community of software
available to operate
Kubernetes within GPC.
GDC comes with much
security and confidentiality
features built in.
A local certificate
authority backed by an HSM
is provided out of the box.
This allows GDC to meet FIPS
140-2 level 3 compliance.
In addition, GDC
can be configured
to work with an existing HSM
provided by the customer.
Secrets management is provided
using the common secrets API,
but it's backed by the
HSM to make it secure.
Also, GDC benefits from
Google's investment
in making GKE secure, and
all of the enhancements put
into GKE so far, plus
Google's contributions
into the Kubernetes community.
Identity and access
management is
supported using standard
protocols like OADC and SAML
2.0, meaning it
can be configured
to work with existing
identity providers
that our customers have.
And because it's Kubernetes
all the way down,
every aspect of the system
is managed by Kubernetes role
based access control.
If you know GCPE,
you will understand
that IM is it's part of every
control surface within Google
Cloud platform.
Well within Google
Distributed Cloud,
Kubernetes RBAC performs and
operates at that same level,
providing fine-grained
control over all resources.
Additionally, supply chain
security, a top concern,
is something that
we've been working hard
both on the hardware
and software side.
We've been working with Tier
1 providers in each region,
and we require strong
hardware supply chain security
as part of the GCD OEM process.
Additionally, the GKE and
our Google security teams
have been ensuring software
supply chain security
in the Kubernetes OSS
stacks for years and years.
And we've made
many contributions
to making Kubernetes a
safe, reliable system
to run workloads on.
And lastly, everything you do
or perform on Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode is audited.
And these audit logs are
compliant with the NIST 853
standards.
Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode
comes with a
variety of services.
And because it's
built on Kubernetes,
anything out in the
open source community
that runs on
Kubernetes will also
run on Google Distributed Cloud.
We are also working with
third party OEM providers
to provide enterprise versions
of popular open source
packages enabling first
class support and enterprise
features.
Lastly, I'm going to chat
about operations and support,
a key concern when
operating a Cloud.
Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode
has a few different
operational patterns
to support customer needs,
which Andy will cover later.
But importantly, the bring
up in deployment of GDC
will be facilitated by
Google every step of the way.
As mentioned earlier, all
the operational aspects
are provided and
operated by Google,
meaning that
customers do not have
to worry about patching and OS
upgrades, BIOS, firmware, CVE
response, et cetera, et cetera.
Instead, Google makes
this largely push button,
or can even provide the
support and operations
to do that for you.
Additionally, the
ability to support an air
gapped deployments,
Google engineering
is ensuring that
every area comes
with full detailed support
and training resources.
As an anecdote within the
engineering organization
for GDC, any pull
request that's submitted
must come with metadata for
support operations, which
makes engineers think
about the full lifecycle
up front, providing
a higher reliability
and operable system.
And regarding
support, Google GDC
can be used and trusted in
air gapped environments.
Google has developed
new support techniques
and operational techniques
derived from Google SRE best
practices, allowing GDC to
maintain a reliable SLO,
while also providing
trusted user
support without requiring any
data to leave the GDC instance.
Importantly for all
operations, Google
is the only vendor a
customer has to call.
And lastly,
localized management.
So in addition to local UI,
local APIs, control plane,
everything being on as
part of the GDC instance
in air gapped or
other environments,
documentation and
access to support
is also built in,
meaning that users do not
need any outside access
to operate and use GDC.
Now, in rare cases, if
the customer desires
faster support, we
will offer a way
to send sanitized
logs, so they could
be shared with the core
engineering teams, increasing
support turnaround.
With that, I'm going to
pass the baton back to Andy.
Thank you very much.
ANDY QIN: Thank you, Ray.
To sum it up, Google
Distributed Cloud Hosted Mode
gives you the power of Cloud
innovation with control.
And it covers all
aspects of sovereignty.
Data is on customer premise
or any data center designated
by the customer.
It can be operated by a customer
directly or by an operating
partner that has the right
credentials and the trust
from the end customer.
Google will train
and work closely
with those chosen partners
to ensure the service
availability.
In certain scenarios, Google
can also operate the deployment
directly with cleared and
certified operational teams.
Its build with
open API, and means
a lot when customers
want to ensure
business continuity in any
potential black swan events.
And it definitely helps
to meet local government's
regulatory requirements.
Google Distributed
Cloud Hosted Mode--
RAY COLLINE: --the benefits
of Cloud delivered locally.
ANDY QIN: This
concludes our session.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you, Ray, for being
part of this conversation.
RAY COLLINE: Thank you
for having me, Andy.
And I hope all of you have a
great rest of the time at Next.